ce qu'il ne fallait pas louper à la télé
comprenez vous que marlène schiappa
soient scandalisés par mon incroyable
mariage gitan alors je ne sais pas si
vous avez eu l'occasion de tomber sur
cette émission c'était sur tf6 nom vient
de découvrir comment elle n ya pas
regarder theft voilà marlène et bah
bravo tsx chl un pas qu'elle existait
bien de pousser un gros coup de gueule
contre l'émission incroyables mariage
gitan dans une lettre ouverte
elle pointe notamment les fameuses
cérémonie du mouchoir la manière dont
est amené la cérémonie du mouchoir
visant à prouver la virginité des jeunes
filles dont certaines ne sont pas
majeurs me choque particulièrement cette
pratique est décrite comme étant le vrai
moment du mariage au mépris des lois de
la république nos textes sont clairs le
mariage doit être célébré à la mairie
entre personnes majeures dans une salle
ouverte au public toute l'institution
républicaine du mariage est bafouée dans
cette émission sans un commentaire
adéquate en voix off alors on va vous
montrer sa cérémonie de mouchoirs pour
moi c'est une strate tradition la wii
cela ne va pas non plus changé les
traditions j'aime beaucoup marlène 1
mais j'ai beaucoup de potes gitans que
j'embrasse d'ailleurs et c'est une
tradition après on va changer toutes les
traditions scénario tout regarder les
mariés ne sont pas encore vraiment
considéré comme mari et femme
pour cela il faut attendre la fameuse
cérémonie du mouchoir
j'attends les joueurs
tiens pas 6 en or que nous désirons les
honneurs c'est le mot pudique des
anciens pour nommer la virginité de la
jeune mariée toutes les femmes se
pressent autour d'elle celle qu'on nomme
l'appliquent à doha va vérifier que
l'hymen de la jeune fille est intacte
nicolas le père du marié étant du même
eto'o si ils savent que si nos ennemis
n'est pas vierge
le mariage sera annulée tout d'un la
pique à doha exhibe le mouchoir
l'honneur de la famille est sauf
voilà alors c'est alors je vous montrais
d'auto de séquences à qui ont choqué
marlène schiappa est ce que vous
comprenez que marié ne soit pas soit
scandalisé par mon incroyable mariage
gitan non non moi je suis d'accord avec
vous et c'est une tradition faut pas
chambouler les traditions et moi si tu
n'es pas c'est qu'elle s'en prend au
traitement journalistique de l'émission
ou non c'est la réalité
ils sont là pour filmer la réalité et
elle s'en prend la voir enfin prêts
peuvent faire un petit c'est ça oui mais
lavrov n'a pas faire de commentaire elle
décrit ce qui se passe n'a pas à dire
non mais ça c'est vous produisez liste
non pas du tout je revends sully sandoz
eyepet il est partout ici non mais je
trouve sympa dans la question prennent à
la forme qu'elles ne soient pas d'accord
avec le fond d'accord mais là le
reportage pour le coup ils font leur job
là c'est justement j'ai vu l'émission et
je trouvais effectivement bouleversant
un moment il ya eu celle qui allait être
ma qualif mariée elle pleurait elle
impressionne c'est pas la question et on
va les voir les extraits d'accord et
nous ce que vous en pensez mais je pense
qu'avec deux avaient travaillé on s'en
fout je l'annoncé que je suis tombé
dessus par hasard et je joue je pense
qu'elle a tort de s'en prendre à cette
tradition gitane qui est très important
pour eux le mariage il ya tout un tas
d'autres traditions intéressante et
c'est dommage sans problème alors dans
l'émission des coûts ce que serait le
rôle de la femme selon les gitans ces
cas dans cette émission et vous allez
voir
voilà alors c'est ça aussi qui l'a génie
à maghnia pas mais je vous le dis je dis
bien c'est dans cette émission il faut
pas non plus faire un amalgame ne faut
pas faire une généralité
je vous dis j'ai énormément de potes
vraiment j tu en voilà et et je vais
vous dire il faut arrêter de dire les
chignons il faut six listes ont épousé
les gitans ils vivent comme nous ben
voilà ils vont ils vous voilà dans le
signal a beaucoup dit donc faut arrêter
de stigmatiser
c'est vrai que voilà moi je sache ça m'a
énervé regardez cdi temps le rôle de la
femme est tout tracé
mais il ira travailler quand il rentrait
du travail du franc manger voilà quoi
c'est comme ça quand pas chez nous les
femmes c'est pour rester à la maison
nous fallait faire manger ce que des
enfants kayhan tu vas nous manquer elles
sont d'autant plus ému que ce sont leurs
derniers moments ensemble dès qu'elle
sera marié lindsay devra s'occuper
exclusivement de son mari oui là alors
gilles verdez vous êtes choqués oui je
suis choqué et comme vous je pense qu'
il ne faut pas du tout du tout
stigmatiser le mode de vie des gitans
mais là à propos de l'émission y'a pas
de contrepoint et on nous montre donc
cette cérémonie des mouchoirs qui est en
fait c'est ça qui peut déranger il n'y a
pas de contrepoids cela dit marine ça
mais voilà ce que j'avance il voulait se
finir mais le bel ses battements où sera
donné par les matchs et remy il n'y a
pas d' équilibre et on nous montre comme
ça comme s'il fallait la prendre telle
quelle une cérémonie des mouchoirs qui
est en fait un test de virginité
alors qu'il ya un texte qui vient d'être
votée à l'assemblée nationale par grâce
à marlène schiappa pour interdire ces
tests de virginité donc l'émission
aurait dû créer un équilibre
y a pas d' équilibre je suis tout à fait
choqué par ce manque d'équilibré vous
êtes choqués bout de film mais choqué je
comprends que marraine chiapas à chaud
qui choqués par dont les traditions sont
faites parfois pour évoluer on fait que
de parler du rôle de la femme dans les
communautés gitane aussi un jour ça
évoluera en ce sens là donc au bout d'un
moment je pense que dans quelques années
ces images là vont nous choquer ciel
nous choque pas aujourd'hui alors il
jouera deux matches est exactement sur
la ligne de delphine effectivement alors
oui effectivement les missions que c'est
un peu l'amalgamme c'est-à-dire qu'elle
elle jette un peu le discrédit sur toute
une communauté
c'est vraiment la faute de l'émission
mais moi à titre personnel effectivement
quand on parle aujourd'hui l'égalité
hommes femmes
après tout guillaume tu disais oui c'est
des us et coutumes dont pourquoi pas oui
l'excision si je l'entendais dire que je
voulais à dire départ et mais malgré
tout moi je trouve que c'est très
violent aujourd'hui de comprendre qu'on
ait approuvé la virginité d'une femme
pour qu'elle la série d'accords voilà
deux mois
non mais il ya peut-être des gens mais
sauf que peut-être des gens se font les
dents une dans un pays qui interdit ça
donc en fait il va être dans la loi
sinon hors d'elle ou alors dans la nuit
d'un autre explique a fait beaucoup
réagir
c'est regarder c'est la vision de
l'homosexualité
j'ai donc a fait énormément réagir est
ce que ce témoignage vous choque je vous
pose la question ici elle s'appelle
tania elle a 33 ans et elle est
homosexuel elles mêmes marie avec sa
compagne elle sait que dans sa
communauté encore plus qu'ailleurs
l'homosexualité est considérée comme une
ronde pendant des années tania a eu peur
de révéler sa sexualité et tous les
soirs demande augmente et justement que
kim à daha pouvoir annoncer ça ma
famille ça arrive que les émotions
oui on leur donne quand même le droit de
faire leur vie mais caché mais on en
donne quand même le droit on veut plus
les voir ils font là envie de leur côté
la famille fait sa vie de l'autre stats
et moi d'âge très fort ça oui isabelle
mais vous vous trompez de genre
journalistique c'est pas une enquête
c'est un reportage
donc pour le coup et gamme n'est pas de
coutume le truc à dire en voix off et de
réserve a apporté ce qu'on est trop des
bus relais de chapa soit scandale enron
aqua marielle temps par cette émission
est non moi je trouve que c'est très
instructive non je ne comprends pas
parce que je trouve que c'est
extrêmement instructif qu'on condamne ou
qu'on soit pour le rite
le fait est que le reportage fait
réfléchir en soi donc il est il est tel
qu'il est il existe et il est pour moi
il est bien isabella nous a fait nos
fossés pernikoff à non mais attendez il
ya les deux questions la question les
homosexuels c'est pas une tradition une
coutume donc ça c'est condamnable exact
normal c'est normal après les traditions
et des coutumes qu'on peut pas remettre
en cause comme ça sur un plateau télé ou
sur vos placements les ministres mais ça
c'est un vrai c'est un vrai discours de
fond il faut respecter les traditions et
coutumes de certaines nadeau qu'on ne
comprenait pas que marlène schiappa sous
son nez à mais je ne comprends pas du
tout coupé n'y avait pas sans poser la
question sur l'homosexualité ou là où je
suis plus d'accord c'est plus une
tradition a reçus voilà donc là on voit
ce qu'on reste restons bien sûr est ce
que vous comprenez que mme aïcha pas se
scandaliser par mon incroyable mariage
gitan je vous montrais un autre extrait
il y a
certains et certaines qui arrive à
casser les codes et veulent faire bouger
les choses c'est notamment le cas de
negrita une femme qui souhaite que les
traditions évolué regarder negrita est
une femme à part elle est parvenue à
briser des tabous dans la communauté
elle joue de la guitare même si
d'habitude la musique est interdite aux
femmes
elle a même osé quitter son mari alors
que c'est interdit chez les gitans
negrita espère que comme elles toutes
les petites filles du conte oseront se
rebeller contre ses traditions quel
juste d'un autre âge mais bon peut-être
avec le temps j'espère vraiment que ça
va évoluer
je me suis battu des années des années
des années pour pouvoir être ce que je
suis aujourd'hui quand c'est très
positif très instructif et le reportage
du tout en fait
donc je comprends pas en quoi on est
choqué par ce reportage qui justement
est extrêmement révélateur de coutume
qu'on peut effectivement condamné ou
apprécier vacances et voilà c'est ça la
question
mais quand je pense que maija pas en
blanc 7
ce tweet ou cette pop soul à je pense
qu'elle fait un acte politique comme il
y avait beaucoup de mesdames ans de
polémiques autour des communautés des
uns des autres
ll est obligé de pointer du doigt ce
reportage pour ce camp ou à l'autre elle
n'aurait pas fait ces points je suis
désolée elle le fait uniquement parce
que on a parlé de communauté juive de
communautés arabes et serra et
qu'aujourd'hui il faut pas et où il faut
sortir de tout ça et c'est dommage que
pour le coup notre reportage ou à des
traductions en toile et certificat de
virginité lancé par avk celle ci va pas
rentrer mais ce n'est pas non il est
vrai que par du débat politique je vais
juste dans ce cas précis je pense que
c'est un acte politique pour x pour
justifier la politique globale autour
des communautés
c'est tout ce que je dis après à 70
euros mais moi dans ce reportage y a
rien de choquant froid n'a pas fauté
je suis choqué par benjamin et nicolas
je suis désolé un coup dur qui ravissent
anges mais là vous dites c'est des
coutumes vous vous dites qu'on va pas
changer les coutumes
non je dis pas ça mais là bas si vous
avez alors je vais vous répondre parce
que negrita par exemple est une amie de
25 ms connais très bien écrite a elle
même écrit par terry je peux pas le
blairer
c'est pas possible je la connais bien et
je vais même vous il ya un trophée gva
amende et j'ai travaillé avec elle j'ai
travaillé avec elle l a fait
effectivement ce maïs est une chanteuse
et son lien il faut quand même savoir
qu'au départ les femmes ne peuvent pas
faire de guitare elle a été la première
à se battre pour pouvoir faire la
guitare a été la première à se battre
aussi entre autres sur l'épreuve de
vérité est en train de plus en plus
d'être le porte parole y avoir de ça
donc
mais c'est son rôle et c'est son rôle à
elle met la lumière la question c'est
vers des drogues dites ce que vous
disiez à nicolas christian c'était vous
avez dit à quelques minutes on va pas
changer les études mais les croyants il
faut respecter les coutumes bien gilles
laissés par les jcc religion n'en suis
très proche la polygamie la polygamie et
on a le droit donc vous êtes pour qu'on
garde la polygamie
je suis fort quand cette fois cette
religion en inde roja polygamie donc
faut pas changer ça c'est aussi de vivre
mais la panacée car il suggère nicolas
mélange pas tout c'est vous je suis
désolé n'est pas le droit de dire ça
qu'est ce qui est à castaldi non je suis
pas d'accord avec lui il doit dire
maintenant dans ce qu'on voit là excuse
moi il me semble qu'il ya pas de
contraintes sont c'est une tradition on
n allait pas obligé de le faire et il
n'y a pas de quoi est entamée à l'excès
de le faire en tout les cas on est plus
à la maison bâton de marie aux affaires
l'aquila moi j'ai pas bu mais j'ai pas
vu des jeunes filles traumatisées et
malheureuse après aldo la liberté de pas
il ya sept de jeune fille qui témoigne
que homosexuels qui dit moi j'ai fait un
autre choix et qui a pris cette décision
pour quoi vous voulez toujours non
minutes et non pas d'accord mais la
lutte est en forte jusqu'à elle peut
s'exprimer
donc c'est moi je t'aime jours et je
suis et je vous dis juste que c'est ce
dont on parle de shyamalan a fait ça
uniquement pour équilibrer tout ce
qu'ils y sur les uns et sur les autres
voilà ce que je vous dit il
et puis à l'ère de twitter elle a pris
un petit extrait du monde hors contexte
on risque de rendre ces camps ce qui
peut choquer quand on voit que cette
séquence de 30 secondes gilles tu
parlais de contrepoids toute heure là on
a vu deux extraits de contrepoids avec
des gens qui se rebellent contre ça
voilà ça très bien de montrer des
traditions qui sont certes ancestrale
voir un peu choquant mais qui existe et
c'est bien de les montrer il faut pas
les censurer et de montrer aussi les
gens qui se rebellent contre ça donc
c'est très bien comme tout ni dedans
alors évidemment je suis d'accord avec
par mois isabelle non je suis obligé
d'être solidaire avec marlène schiappa
quant à dire que on est forcé plus ou
moins d'être d'accepter
elle a dit exactement on peut pas
accepter pour les autres femmes ce qu'on
ferait à nos soeurs ou à d'autres femmes
et je suis d'accord avec elle parce que
c'est quelque chose qui me cesser ces
mots c'est des pratiques coutumières qui
me dépasse pardon et quand on parle
justement de polygamie de mariages
forcés de perdre virginité sais pas mais
non mais même si c'est même si c'est
quelque chose qui existe depuis la nuit
des temps c'est pas parce que c'est
des temps qu'il faut continuer à le
faire perdurer et moi en tout cas c'est
quelque chose qui me dépasse donc je me
range du côté de marlène chapin dos
alors bon alors j'ai apprécié je me suis
donc à perdre on peut plus faire en
france il ya plein tradition veut plus
faire pour empêcher les gens de fêter
l'aïd payant la dame attendait non on va
donc ça aussi c'est une faute et envers
un animal
excuse moi ça me choque aussi pour
pousser l'engin moutons et pourtant je
dirais oui mais c'est la loi ça abbas
est là où à travers nos assez bien donc
on va laisser faire tout les traditions
je trouve que honnêtement je fais je
trouve que vous êtes un discours vous
choisissez possible effectivement moi ça
me choque pas l'aïd mais on peut pas
reprocher des choses d'un côté ne pas
embaucher de l'autre c'est tout ce que
je vis à la loi la loi rien ta loi il me
semble qu'aujourd'hui égorgé un animal
havas temps en temps tu peins pour les
crabes de koh lanta delà du délai pour
importer ou c'est pas la même chose nous
dit que c'est leur sujet pardon mais là
ce dont on est en train de parler c'est
pas le sujet ces sujets semés et
traditions bien ici sait rien elle
montre le reportage je suis déçu de ne
pas passer l'année seront sans tabou en
italie naples au jdd qui ne sont pas de
ça on en en train de de d'extrapoler la
politique sur la télé on a là où vous et
votre ténèbres logistique sont là bas
c'est vrai
on s'emballe arras oui la même chose
merci benjamin tu ne peux pas faire
abstraction malgré tout de nos lois et
de notre cadre républicain soit c'est
dans la loi ça ça va te défoncer à votre
défaut et moi je vous dis
jusqu'aujourd'hui mois par rapport à la
loi aujourd'hui on pourrait très bien
mais ce n'est pas du tout mon discours
mais il a j'ai dit ah que c'est un
scandale
les gens pourraient dire je suis choqué
je voudrait interdire qu'on égorge des
moutons de l'aïd
c'était hors la loi bah écoutez alors je
sais pas on a mille fois sur ce plateau
du fait de respecter des animaux de
palais le palais ne pas les massacres et
de respecter leur mode fun mort prop
excuse moi non j'ai pas d'accord il est
deux points avec arsenal qu'il fait dans
mais qu'à ce stade il est parti dans un
délire aussi je pense à vous et moi non
mais l'énergie nommé jeu j'essaie de
raisonner avec les vols avec des
exemples forts qu'on comprenne c'est sûr
qu'on comprenne que tu vois pas pourquoi
ou alors on s'arc boutent contre le
contrôle moi je sais que vous avez eue
il ya une phrase qui vous a énervé c'est
la phrase de nicolas pernikoff qui dit
on va pas changer les traditions non
mais je les ai dit j'ai dit aussi cette
phrase non mais je vous dis oui c'est
vrai dit voilà il ya plein de tradition
alors moi moi je vous dire j'en ai ras
le cul aussi que tous les politiques
s'alarme hills et dont la mission dans
la société et les gitans
ça fait des années qu'ils font ça et les
chutes ont il est vrai il faut l'épauler
laisser faire il faut les laisser vivre
leurs traditions folie les bibles envier
à chaque fois on va les robes à casser
les couilles à tout le monde
l'assesseur de gamme et loire qui ne
progresse ça évolue aussi à nous de dire
c'est pas donné c'était à nous de dire
aux gens ce qu'ils doivent faire être
pas faire voilà l arrivée 4 virginité si
c'est un non remise à la société
géraldine pas des gens ont le droit de
vivre comme ils l'entendent sont
maintenant que dès mardi sur les docks
de tradition la jouer les deux jeunes
femmes qu'ils hébergent le plein de
giteau qui respectent pas les caniches
awad a souvent dit de le faire voilà les
deux jeunes femmes qui disaient la wii
moi j'ai envie d'être à la maison pour
mon mari s'étaient montrés comme c'est
choquant et ses salves ont envie de
faire ça absolument attirer qui et
marlène schiappa pour dire non fait pas
ci fais pas ça faut faire s'il veut
faire ça c'est les boules à 100 sur 100
m chappuis à un pote bien potes qui
m'envoie un message incognito
les gens font l'amalgamé entre les
gitans et les gens du voyage attention
benjamins région à chaque famille ses
choix mais c'est très rare aujourd'hui
que les familles impose alors leur fille
a épousé tel ou tel mec c'est n'importe
quoi fréron dollars ces dames du
programme voilà exact il n'y a pas voilà
un peu raison puisqu'il n'y avait pas de
contrepoids dans le programme donc merci
à mon
héros merci à 110 110 gitans qui m'a
écrit mon chéri d'amour je t'aime fort
et j'espère que je te vois semaine
prochaine voilà donc c'est vrai que
voilà je vous dis c'est dans le sait
dans le reportage qui a été
c'est le reportage ils ont voulu faire
du sensationnalisme voici comment et on
le comprend par le comprend on comprend
pas mais on sait ces voix là ils ont
voulu faire du sensationnalisme pour
faire pour faire de l'audience est
normal et on le voit ils ont montré ça
parce que mes mais cci c'est une infime
minorité c'est ce que m'a dit à mon pote
voilà et là où se trouve un jamais
raison malgré tout c'est que marine
chapa aujourd'hui c'est vrai qu'on parle
beaucoup de la communauté musulmane et
bien sûr c'était une manière de
rééquilibrer le débat on dire vous avez
vu quand même je mal je m'attaque à
toutes les communautés quand je dois
qu'à une dérive malgré tout et sam bird
art aux républicains alors voilà parce
qu'il a raison le cierge et voilà et je
vais vous dire
sachez que voilà comme m'a dit mon pote
les gîtes ont aussi évolué avec leur
tradition il veut et que voilà c'est
fini on va pas présenter c'est fini les
présentations etc
maintenant ça ça se fait plus nulle part
comme vous l'a dit c'est vrai que ça
évolue aussi un élément mais on a un
petit peu marre tout ceci que les gens
nous disent qu'il faut faire et pas
faire l'erreur de le signer pour moi
noël chaque appel
alors là je prends cet exemple l'arrêt
des donneurs de leçons on n'en peut plus
en ce moment et c'est vrai que c'est un
supporter ap les donneurs de leçons
qu'ils sont c'est pas sur cette chaîne